[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHARLOTTE RELYEA:
I'm Charlotte Relyea.
As Tara said, I lead our
Women's Initiative at McKinsey.
And this is a topic that's
near and dear to my heart.
And I assume a pretty timely
topic right now for all of you.
I'm going to share
some of our insights
from our Women in the
Workplace research
that we do together
with Lean In.
And we're in our
second year of doing
a survey of approximately--
about 130 companies
have participated, about
34,000 participants.
And those companies
represent about almost five,
or 4 and 1/2 million employees.
So a lot of great
insights that we've been
able to get out of the data.
And as I mentioned,
this is a topic
that's really near
and dear to my heart.
So in addition to spending a
lot of time on women's issues
at McKinsey, I'm a mother.
I have a daughter.
And you know, I'm
always thinking
about how is this world
going to be different
when she is in the
workplace and how can we
make that happen together?
So before I get
into the research,
I wanted to lay a little bit
of the groundwork for why
this is a topic that
people should care about.
Other than a lot of the obvious
reasons, the economic case
is real.
So we did research, in our
power of parity research,
where we looked at different
regions across the globe
and estimated what
the impact would
be if women achieved parity.
And that's impact of about $28
trillion, if we close the gap.
You know, recognizing that's
slightly unreasonable,
we also said, well, what if
each company within its region--
sorry, each country,
within its region,
were able to reach parity
or the pace of change
of the fastest changing
countries in the region?
And that has an impact
about $12 trillion.
So this is a huge number,
obviously, and something
that we all need to care about.
In the US, this impact
is about $2.1 trillion.
So this is bigger
than the GDP of Texas.
And there's three main gaps to
close in order to get parity.
One is participation.
So in the US, it's about 40%
of the gap is participation.
30% from moving people from
part-time to full-time,
and then 30%
productivity, and that's
essentially people in lower
wage or lower productive jobs
or sectors and with pay gaps.
So if those things close,
we would see $2.1 trillion.
So at the company level,
what's the case for change?
We typically look at
it in four lenses.
So one is the more obvious,
most obvious one, values, right?
A second one is around talent.
Third is performance, there's
an actual link to performance
and gender diversity.
And finally, the
customer-- how do
we actually relate
more to our customer
base that's making decisions?
Primarily, there are a lot
of women making the decisions
in the household.
So first, if you
think about values,
women make up a huge portion
of the workplace, right?
But if you look at their pay
gap, women are making about 20%
less than men.
And furthermore,
there's actually
a differential in what
happens when there's positive
versus negative performance.
So in times of
positive performance,
women tend to get less of
a bump and share in less
of the upside, and actually
get penalized more when
there's negative performance.
So the meritocracy,
while it's important
and it's something that we all
talk about, it's not there yet.
Talent-- so winning the war
for talent, needless to say,
means getting more women.
Today, college graduates, women
that are college graduates,
represent 58% of the
college graduate population.
And so if you want
to get talent,
you need to get women both
right out of college, but also
at every stage in the pipeline.
Performance-- there
have been many studies.
I know you've done
a lot of studies
at Google on the
power of diverse teams
and diversity of thought.
The research that
we've done shows
that gender diverse
companies outperform by 15%,
and ethnically diverse
companies outperform by 35%.
So there's a real case for
performance in diversity.
And finally, the
customer-- so women
are making a lot of the
decisions in the household.
This is obviously
in the BBC world.
But if you think
about that, actually
having a diverse organization
that's serving those households
is quite important.
So now, let's turn to the women
in the workplace research.
For starters, we've
been benchmarking
this for about 10 years.
We've been benchmarking
and studying
women in the workplace,
the pipeline, the data,
for about 10 years.
Over the past few
years, we've also
started expanding
to also benchmark
and look at the experiences
and attitudes of men and women
as well.
So we'll get into that.
But when you look at
the trends, the data
trends of the
pipeline, it's going
to take-- given the
glacial pace at which we're
moving-- it's going to take
about 100 years to reach gender
parity in the
C-suite, 100 years.
So I'm personally hoping that we
can speed that up a little bit.
Because I'd like
my daughter to be
able to have a
better chance and not
have to wait till my
great-granddaughter
to see parity.
So what does the corporate
pipeline look like?
And this is US data by the way.
But when we look at the European
data, it's relatively similar.
The corporate pipeline
is not looking great.
So our results from
this year reaffirm
what we keep seeing, what we've
seen over the past 10 years.
Which is women are represented
at every level in the pipeline,
in the organization.
And the numbers aren't
changing much year after year.
We're going to come
back to this one.
But despite a misperception,
this is not due to attrition,
right?
This is actually
due to promotion
and some other factors.
So we'll come back to that.
If you look at women of
color, it's even worse, right?
It's even more stark.
So at the C-suite, instead of
17%, you see 3%, for example.
And if you look at some of
"The Wall Street Journal"
research on the ambition
of women of color,
black, Hispanic and
Asian women are--
48% of them said they aspire
to be a top executive, compared
with 37% of white women.
So there's not a
lack of ambition
on the part of women of color.
So now going back to attrition,
it is not the driving factor.
And this is a very
common misperception,
and clearly, this is a
myth busting piece of data.
But if you look at-- this
is attrition by tenure.
And men actually attrite
faster than women.
Which means it's not that
women are leaving, right?
And often, look, the
one caveat to this
is, this doesn't necessarily
say where the men are going.
So they might actually be going
into another position, similar,
to another organization.
But still, if you
look at this, it's
not saying that the
reason why we're
losing women at
more senior levels
is because they're leaving.
So let's talk about
the challenge.
The challenge starts early,
at the very first milestone.
For every 100 women
promoted, about 130 men
are promoted at the
first promotion.
So this is from the entry
level position to manager,
for example.
And then we also see
discrepancy in hiring
throughout the pipeline.
So what that means is it
just keeps getting worse.
So not only are we promoting men
at a faster rate at the earlier
stages, but we're also
bringing in more men
throughout the funnel.
And furthermore, we're promoting
women at a slower rate.
So all of these things
are contributing
to the state of the pipeline.
So now let's turn for a moment
to the second part of what
I had originally mentioned,
which is not just the pipeline
data, but the experience data.
So what are the attitudes of
men and women in the workplace
and how does that
explain some of the data?
I want to start by getting
a little bit of involvement
from you in the room.
So first question,
raise your hand if yes,
has your gender been a
disadvantage as you've
climbed the corporate ladder?
Yes, it has.
Raise your hand if it's yes.
First of all, it's
great that a lot of you
have not had that issue.
But I do see, if I look
around the room, probably
more women raising
their hands, which
is consistent with the data.
So if you look at
the data, women
perceive more disadvantages
based on their gender,
and the gap keeps getting
wider as you go more senior.
And when we look at the
actual qualitative data
behind the survey,
women consistently
report feeling that their
contributions are often
valued less than
men, that they're
being turned to less than
men for important decisions,
that they're participating
less meaningfully in meetings,
and often they're receiving
fewer challenging assignments
than men.
Other research that
we've done often
shows that men get
stretch assignments
and are promoted
based on potential,
whereas often women
are promoted based
on performance and the
history of their performance.
And one other factoid on
millennials, which is,
you'd hope that this is
changing for millennials.
But actually,
millennials have answered
these questions in
very similar ways
to the rest of the workforce.
So another question--
raise your hand if yes.
Do you have meaningful
access to senior leadership?
Yes?
OK, all right, better, better.
So men and women also report
having different access
to senior leaders and networks.
So this is also another
case where the gap grows.
And particularly at
more senior levels
where access to
senior leadership
is especially important for
sponsorship and for promotion,
it gets worse.
And one of the
reasons behind this
also has to do with networks.
So women tend to have
networks, our research shows,
that are 50/50, women, men.
And then men tend
to have networks
that are primarily male.
So if you then think
about, within my network,
just if you do the math,
it has to be true, right,
that women just have smaller
networks if that's the case.
Because we know that
there are so many
more men in senior
ranks, or they
have smaller networks
of senior leaders.
And so what does that mean?
Obviously, we need to get more
women in senior positions.
But we also need to make sure
that men are mentoring women.
That's a big, big gap, and
we'll come back to that one.
But often people tend
to mentor others that
are very similar to themselves.
They don't feel as
comfortable, men
might not feel comfortable
taking a woman out to drinks,
if that's the way the
mentorship relationship begins,
and things like that.
So how do you actually
start becoming very--
and this is a call to action
for the men in the room--
how can you get
really purposeful
about thinking about who you
want to mentor and sponsor
within your organization?
Which women you're going to
really take under your wing?
Because that makes
a huge difference.
So how about this, do you
feel that you've received
as much feedback as your peers?
Raise your hand if yes.
OK, a little bit of a
mix, a little of a mix.
So our research shows that women
receive less feedback than men,
and more specifically, the
tough developmental messages.
OK, so what does that mean?
Especially as you
get more senior,
hearing the tough messages
that help you develop
is extremely important to
developing and progressing.
And not only men,
but women actually
have a harder time telling the
hard messages to other women.
So both men and women
worry that they're
going to create an
emotional response
or that they are going to be
perceived as mean or hurtful.
I mean, this goes back to a
lot with unconscious bias,
but by giving a woman feedback.
And if you think about
that, then that's
doing a tremendous disservice,
tremendous disservice.
Because we know that people grow
through developmental feedback.
And so how can we all ask
ourselves, are we doing that?
Right?
Are you giving the hard
but important messages
to women in the same way
that you're giving to men?
And if you're not, how might
you shift your mindset to say,
you know, my intention is
to help this person grow.
And so being mean or
hurtful is not the issue.
It's about using the
intention, a positive intent.
So have you ever been called
aggressive, intimidating,
demanding, or bossy?
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
This is a great culture.
I'm with you.
I'm raising my hand,
too, by the way.
So the good news--
we looked at this from
the following angle.
We said, how many people are
more likely to negotiate?
Whether it's for higher pay or
a promotion or something else--
are you willing to negotiate?
And the good news
is that women are
negotiating at the same rate
as men, so we're doing it.
But the bad news is that women
get unduly penalized, right,
for being bossy and aggressive.
So what that means is that the
percentage of women and men
that were called bossy,
aggressive, or intimidating
is much higher for the women
that negotiated versus the men.
And by the way, 19% of
the women who didn't even
say they negotiated feel
like they're being called
those things a lot of the time.
So how do we change the game?
Let's talk about
changing the game.
Three things we've seen in
companies that are the best.
And so first of all, I'm
going to start by saying,
as we saw in the data, we are
far from where we need to be.
And no one company
has cracked the code.
So there's nobody
that's figured it out
and doing it tremendously well.
Lots of companies are
trying different things
and having success
in different ways.
But nobody has cracked the code.
But we looked at some
of the companies that
had over 30% women in
the C-suite, right?
So those that were doing
the best on this dimension.
And we said, what are some of
the things that are common?
So three things, and we'll
dive into them in a minute.
So one is persistence.
Many of these companies,
including McKinsey,
have been at this
for 10 years or more.
We've been talking about it.
We've been looking at the data.
We've been trying
different things.
And it takes time.
It takes time and commitment.
The second one is
the CEO commitment.
So this is not a
social, you know,
nice to have thing on the side.
This is a true
priority from the CEO,
and this is commitment that
cascades all the way down
the organization in the way that
any business initiative would.
That's number two.
And then number three is
holistic change programs.
So again, it's not about a
bunch of policies or programs
on the side.
But it's the holistic
change programs
that engage people throughout
the organization that
include all the
metrics in the data
and monitoring, the way you'd
run any major holistic change
transformation.
All of those elements are true.
So let's dive into that
last one for a moment.
The first part of that is
really making a compelling case
for diversity.
It's not just about saying it.
So if you look at this,
right, almost 80% of companies
claim the gender
diversity is a priority.
But the employees
don't really buy it.
So this is the
percentage of people
that say my manager,
or sales leaders,
or senior leaders, or my CEO
consider this a priority.
They don't buy that
companies are actually
make it a priority.
And why is that?
Well, we looked at some
of these organizations.
And even companies that look
great on paper-- they've
got amazing policies,
they've got work from home,
they've got flexible work style,
they've got parental leave,
they have lots of community
events and efforts.
But if they're not
walking the walk,
if it's not clear
to the organization
that it's actually OK to take
advantage of those programs,
and that it's championed that
you're part of those things,
people don't do them.
They might exist.
People don't do them.
They think, you know,
going on a longer maternity
leave is a kiss of death.
It's my walk down the path
of the downward cycle.
So companies also, therefore,
need to be talking about it,
right?
There's lots of companies
that are talking about it.
I think you're probably--
you are all talking
about it a lot right now.
We can continue
to talk about it.
But the CEOs need
to be very clear
that this is a
priority, that there
is a business case behind it,
that we're making it happen.
And so here's just a couple
of examples of organizations
like P&G and JP Morgan that
are really putting muscle
behind making this a
priority for the organization
and talking about it a lot.
So secondly, this is about
policy, right, and procedure,
the way in which you do
hiring, reviews, promotions,
making sure that there's
real equity there.
There's real gender
discrepancies
in how people perceive
fairness at work.
So people really feel that
it is not quite as fair
as the companies
say it is, right?
And particularly women
feel that promotions
and getting opportunities,
they are at a disadvantage.
We've talked about that
before within the data.
But how do you act
to change that?
So there are a
few things, right,
if you look at just
how do you do it
in the different stages of
talent management, so hiring,
reviews, and promotions.
A big thing,
particularly when hiring,
but also within
reviews and promotions,
is unconscious bias.
So how do you really
figure out ways
to remove unconscious bias?
There's organizations that are
doing blind resume screening,
that are bringing in new
games and ways of applying
to the organization
that don't require
seeing somebody face to face.
But it's rather
looking at their work
or looking at or
listening to their music
or what have you before there's
a face to face interaction
so there's absolutely no bias.
And those
organizations that have
done that type of blind
screening actually
find much more parity in
their hiring practices.
You know, VMware, for example,
this is in the reviews,
they actually train
managers right
before they would write a review
to remove unconscious bias.
So they remind people
about gender biases.
They remind people about
potentially loaded phrases,
like women, you know, needing
to have more presence, things
like that.
And they write it,
they have a memo,
and every manager is required to
read it right before they write
their performance reviews.
So putting it top
of mind in people
right at the moment
of writing review.
Similarly, on promotions,
often some organizations
are requiring that
slates for promotions
always have a certain
percentage of women on them.
That's not to say that the
women are getting promoted.
It's not a quota.
It's not a quota for promotion.
It's not meant to steer the
actual promotion itself.
It's just meant
to say, often what
happens is, the slate doesn't
have enough women on it
and so it ends up
going to a man.
So if you actually just
make sure the slate has it,
that ends up having impact.
And again, keeping in mind
that the promotion itself
is based on meritocracy.
But that it's just
the slate that
has been sort of forced
to really make sure
that people are
removing their bias
and putting different
profiles on it.
So the third is
accountability and results,
so focusing on
accountability and results.
And we've talked about
this, you know, a bit.
And the idea that if
you don't measure it,
it doesn't happen, right?
Like, if you can't see it,
if you don't measure it,
if you don't call it
out, if people are not
accountable to these
metrics, then it's not
going to do anything, right?
And so if you look at this,
I mean, 40% of companies
are saying they
hold their leaders
accountable for performance
against gender diversity.
Going back to 80% of the
companies say it's a priority.
But only 40% are holding
leaders accountable.
And a very small
percentage of employees
agree that the progress is
actually being measured,
and gender diversity
is being measured.
So some of the things
that we're seeing here
are how can you literally just--
how are different
organizations publicizing
their pipeline, their funnel?
How different
managers are doing,
oftentimes managers don't even
realize what they're doing.
So by actually
giving them the data,
this is how many people
you interviewed last year,
and this is the percentage
of them that were women,
and this is your
promotion rate of women,
and this is the way
in which you've been--
if you go through and look at
all your performance reviews,
these are the types of comments
you have on women versus men.
Really starting to bring to
light what's happening as a way
to create a lot of
visibility and opportunity.
You know, for example, Ikea has
made achieving a 50/50 gender
split one of the key metrics
that managers are evaluated on.
Salesforce publishes diversity
numbers as we all know, right?
In 2015, Marc
Benioff said that he
had the goal to employ an
equal number of women and men
and thinks that this is
absolutely doable and is
on the path to doing that.
So how do you start to set
those goals and measure them?
Empowering employees
to lead the change--
so one of the
things always we've
also found is, paired with
the whole numbers game
and really making sure that
you're getting diverse numbers
and you're tracking them,
et cetera, is inclusion.
So how do you get
more inclusion?
And that's something
that has been,
I know, probably a very big part
of how you all operate, right?
With the focus on diverse
teams and diversity of thought,
that's exactly what
we're talking about.
How do you actually
create a environment
that feels inclusive
for individuals
of all different
types of backgrounds?
And that's a way to help
create inclusivity for women.
And that's about culture,
and culture change
happens all the way
down the organization
with every last person,
and engaging change agents,
and engaging people in different
pockets of the organization
to really drive this
cultural change.
So lastly, of course,
educating people, right?
Right now, most
employees don't know
how to promote gender
diversity, right?
There's a lot of people
that say we want to do it,
but there's not a lot of
people that know how to do it.
And whether that's telling
your middle managers that,
hey, if you just
literally choose--
if every man in the
middle management
chose to mentor or sponsor
one or two more women,
how much impact that could have.
If senior leaders chose
to sponsor another woman,
if senior leaders chose
to speak out and make
this a priority and
really cascade this down
the organization, the way in
which that can move the needle.
And even at the
entry level, it's
how can you really promote
inclusive practices
from day one?
So it doesn't feel like
a frat or a certain type
of environment that
is not welcoming
to women or other types of--
or other diverse backgrounds.
And then role modeling,
and this is part of it
as well, so actually
calling it out.
I mean this is how women and
men answered whether or not
managers are calling out gender
biased language or behavior.
It is not OK if you hear someone
say something that's offensive.
You just call it out.
I mean, imagine if
everybody called that out.
It just wasn't tolerated.
That makes a huge
difference, right?
Embracing different
leadership styles--
I think that this is
better than calling out,
you know, styles that are
or activities or language
that is negative.
But being able to
embrace there's
lots of different styles and
there's lots of different ways
to be successful here.
And we're going to role
model those different ways
and celebrate
different profiles.
So building this generation
of diversity champions,
training them, celebrating
them, modeling it, right?
How can you celebrate--
people that are diversity
champions, even at McKinsey,
we're starting to
do that, right?
How do we celebrate people that
are making a real difference?
And that's a huge
honor to those people,
and things like that
really start to get
people excited and motivated.
Training them, as we
talked about before,
but what do they need to know?
How do they need to
behave differently?
How can they make a difference?
And making sure that
you're modeling and role
modeling what you want to see.
So what can you do today?
These are a few things.
I'd love to, actually,
even open it up
and hear from you, what
you all think you can do.
But some of the things, just
to start the conversation,
around talking about why
gender diversity matters
to you, both up and down.
Calling out the biases,
as we mentioned.
Not tolerating any behavior
that demonstrates bias.
Creating scorecards and
measuring and monitoring,
changing your language.
Just reminding yourself to use--
remind yourself
to think about it.
Sometimes it's just
as simple as that.
Committing to sponsor women.
And sharing in success
stories of women,
celebrating women that
have done amazing things.
So what are some other
things-- and by the way,
I'm also open to take questions.
But I figured I'd start
with a question to you.
Which is what are some
of the things that you're
doing about it or
that you think Google
should be doing about it?
AUDIENCE: Well, my manager is
sitting two rows behind me.
And with my team,
made the suggestion
that we use a regularly
scheduled kind of tech talk
session where we watch YouTube
videos about technical things
or non-technical
things as a group
and discuss them and
come here instead.
And I think that's
a great, you know,
a great way to improve
gender diversity
and get us talking
about it more.
Admittedly, we've been
talking about it a lot
in the last week.
But it's a great
way for a manager
to have an impact on their
team and spread that knowledge.
[APPLAUSE]
CHARLOTTE RELYEA: Thank you.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So first
of all, thanks
for coming today and
presenting this to us.
The research and
metric driven approach
really hits it home for me.
I love data, and this really
calls it out very clearly.
Focusing on that data, but also
tying in people's perceptions.
Question for you-- you mentioned
call out bias when you see it.
It only takes one voice.
So I've had experiences where
someone will say something,
and it takes me a few
seconds to process
what they've actually said.
And then I'm, like, wait what?
And then I'm like, should
I say something now?
Like, five seconds have already
gone-- now it's 10 seconds.
[LAUGHTER]
And it's, like, so I'm
wondering if you have
any tips for calling that out.
Because it sometimes does take
a little bit of time for me
to process.
And then I'm like 20
seconds has gone by,
what do I do kind of a thing.
Or if anyone else has any tips
as well, I'd love to hear them.
CHARLOTTE RELYEA: I'm
happy to answer that.
I feel like it's never too late.
Just say it.
You can say hey, you
know, took me a minute
because I felt like that was
really inappropriate what
you said.
And I just wanted you to know.
And you could also go
at it with the intent--
I mean, I think another thing,
it's always about intent.
So always assume positive
intent from the other person.
And then you could have a much
greater impact in the feedback
that you're giving.
So hey, I know
you might not have
meant it to come
across this way,
but let me tell you
how it made me feel.
And hey, you might
want to consider
not doing that next time.
AUDIENCE: Awesome, thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I'm a father.
I have four kids, and
one of them is a girl.
And she runs the house.
But I feel like a
lot of the-- or I
believe that a lot
of these things
are a lot deeper
than the workplace.
They're foundational in the
way that we raise our kids
and promote values and
unintentionally buy
pink things for my daughter
and blue things for my sons.
And what things can
we do as parents
and in a sort of
a grassroots sense
and as communities
as we're raising
our kids to help with this?
CHARLOTTE RELYEA: I mean, that--
don't even get me started.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARLOTTE RELYEA:
I think there's
a tremendous amount we can
do as we're raising our kids.
I mean, I can tell you
just personally what I do.
So I have a daughter and a son.
And as much as--
I mean, I try to
congratulate them
for the same types of things.
So a lot of times
parents will tell
the girl they're really pretty.
And they don't even mean it.
Or other people in
their environment
will tell the girl
they're really pretty
and the guy he did really
well on that problem, right?
And so I try to congratulate my
daughter for problem solving,
and tell my son he
looks really cute.
[LAUGHTER]
But no, no, seriously.
And just really thinking
about the language
that you're using, because
that is where it starts.
Like, what are you
getting praise for?
How are people
demonstrating love?
Are you telling your
daughter that she's being
too bossy, like, too early on?
If you see two children
playing, because even if--
no matter what you
do in your household,
you're not going be able
to change what's happening
in other people's households.
But talking about it, right?
And even recognizing, like,
hey, so-and-so said this.
But in our family, this
is what we believe,
and this is how we
conduct ourselves.
So I don't know.
You probably all
have lots of ideas
as well, if anyone
else wants to share.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLOTTE RELYEA:
The question was,
given that we know that
lots of executive promotions
actually are external
hires versus just
internal promotions,
how do executive search
firms and other players
that might be helping
find the slate of candidates
for senior positions
contribute to or
detract from the goal
at hand, which is to
increase the number of women
in these senior
executive positions?
I'll tell you we
haven't specifically
looked at biases, for example,
in executive recruiting
practices.
And actually, I think,
in general most people
when they're talking to
executive recruiters say
they want to see women
candidates, actually.
Because it's a priority for
a lot of senior leaders.
I will say, though,
in the end what
does happen is that more men
are hired in at senior levels
and laterally than women.
So in addition to
different promotion, women
getting promoted
less frequently,
more men are coming in
at more senior levels.
And so for that--
we haven't actually--
so I can hypothesize.
I don't want to
speak for the data,
because we don't actually
have the data underlying that.
But my sense is that
is driven in large part
by a lot of the same biases
that might take place
in the recruiting and selection
process for any role, right?
That you know, the way in
which the job spec is written
is often much more tailored to
a man and a man's background.
Often in the selection process,
there's a bias towards men.
People tend to look
at men, and see,
as I mentioned before,
see a potential.
Whereas women, they
look for performance.
And so the bar tends
to be higher for women.
There's a lot of biases that
take place in that process.
And I think that that's
probably where it's coming from.
I'm not sure it's
purely based on
what's happening at the
executive recruiting
side of things.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for sharing
all this with us.
It's really great to see
practical applications
of things.
So I have one thing
to share that I
feel like has been super
personally helpful for me
on the changing your own
language bit of things.
So a lot of us participate
a ton in both hiring,
so writing reviews
for people who
are coming in as candidates, and
also in the sort of performance
review process when you write
peer reviews for all the people
who are going up for promotion
or just generating feedback.
And taking out gender pronouns
entirely from feedback
that you write, I feel like has
both a big impact on the way
that I write, but
also for people
who are going to just be
reading feedback, right?
This is going to committee.
It's going to a hiring committee
or a performance review
committee for promotions.
Not having gender
pronouns, like,
it does change the way
that you have to write
and the way that you use
adjectives and the way
that people will interpret
what you're writing.
And it's made a big difference
for me in just my personal--
CHARLOTTE RELYEA: That's great.
AUDIENCE: --capabilities
of writing,
I think, useful
feedback about people.
So I'd say for people who
are doing that on their own,
or if you are working
with other people,
even out of your
e-mails, when you're
writing about what
someone else had said,
or recap for a meeting, like,
trying not to rely on those
actually pushes you a
little bit further in giving
useful descriptions of
someone or their projects
or what has happened
in a given scenario.
And it's, like, a really small
change that you can make.
CHARLOTTE RELYEA: Yeah.
I mean, and that's very
aligned to a lot of the resumes
screen--
blind resume screening
tests that have been done.
Where literally,
there have been tests
that have shown the minute
that any understanding of what
the gender is of the
applicant is taken away,
then all of a sudden the
hiring goes to parity.
It's amazing, right, exactly--
like if you can take that
away, how much of a difference
that can make.
AUDIENCE: So I'm white,
Anglo-Saxon Protestant, male,
identify straight, a
manager, so on and so forth.
So like, the bingo of being part
of the privileged class, so as
to speak.
So I'm wondering from
your research looking
at many different
companies, how do you
go straight at that majority
to affect change at scale?
CHARLOTTE RELYEA: How
do you-- sorry what?
AUDIENCE: How have you seen or
how do you go at people like me
at scale in organizations to
make them part of the change
and not rely on
underrepresented groups
to stand up to make that change?
CHARLOTTE RELYEA: Well,
it's literally engaging you
in part of the process, right?
It's engaging you in being
a champion of change,
in signing up to
mentor or sponsor
a set of women, in driving
specific initiatives
within the organization.
In fact, it's really important.
And we've found that
it's really important
that men lead a lot
of these initiatives,
that it's not all women lead.
So I think the real
important thing
is to get people like you
to actually own and do
and lead some of this
and sign up for this.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: One of the things
that I've done as a manager is,
if I see somebody doing things
that I know will be negative
towards them-- so if they
use language of I'm sorry,
or that's the one that always
gets me is the I'm sorry
or I'm bothering you
or things like that--
to literally tell
them, don't say that.
Say it this way,
and this is why.
So call out those small things.
Because I think sometimes
when people hear the word
mentorship, they think, oh,
I've got to take them to lunch.
And I've got to do this,
and I've got to do that.
It's the simple, you're
walking back from the meeting
to your desk.
And say, hey, I
heard you say this.
And it negated what you were
saying because of this reason.
Because people need to hear
that immediately and repeatedly.
And it took me a long time
to learn those things.
CHARLOTTE RELYEA: Well,
yeah, and that goes back
to one of the real
drivers, which
is getting developmental
feedback in hard messages.
And people tend to
not do that for women.
And so telling the
person, don't go
sit on this side of the room.
Sit at the table
when you walk in.
Take the main seat at the table.
Speak up in the meeting.
I want to hear your voice.
Don't use like and
sorry and don't
caveat what you're saying.
Be assertive and forceful, if
you need to, in that meeting.
Like, I think giving that
coaching and that feedback
is quite valuable.
Now of course, not
necessarily trying
to only promote one kind
of leadership style,
right, you also want to
recognize different leadership
styles and some people have more
assertive leadership styles,
and some people have more
quiet leadership styles.
And all that's fine.
But definitely giving feedback
where people are taking away
from their own credibility
or not stepping up
and owning leadership
opportunities the way they can.
I think that's really,
really important.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank
you for reinforcing
much of what we try to do
here at Google with lots
of external data.
That's always necessary.
First, I'd like to
say that was Matt,
and he's actually
one of my mentors.
So he's sort of practicing
what he preaches already.
And I'm like the opposite
of everything he just said.
So kudos to him.
My question is, do you
have data around or a POV
on this idea that, by focusing
on women's empowerment, gender
parity, elevating
women in the workforce,
that that is
discriminatory against men?
CHARLOTTE RELYEA:
I don't think so.
I mean, we're so far from being
discriminatory against men
right now, that I
think it's sort of--
it's cleaning up
some of the issues
rather than trying to put
in place quotas or things
like that.
And so I think if anything is
perceived as discriminatory
against men or if there is
something like a quota that
can be perceived
in that way, that
can be damaging to the
whole cause, right?
But all of the things in the
data that we've shown here
has been about things that
are cleaning up the issues,
not swinging the pendulum the
other way around, I would say.
AUDIENCE: I agree with you.
Just I'm always playing
devil's advocate.
So thank you.
CHARLOTTE RELYEA:
Thank you for that.
No, I appreciate that.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a question in regards
to both gender diversity,
but also age diversity.
So I was speaking with one of
my Google mentors the other day,
and we were talking about
the job postings even
on the Google site.
I don't know if
you guys have seen.
But obviously, it shows x
amount of years of experience.
And he was saying
he read a study
that even though-- so it
says four years of experience
required.
And some men will look at
that, and they only have two,
and they'll be, like,
I'm going to go for it.
Where girls are
like, I have three.
But I'll hold back until I
have that fourth before I
can go for that position.
And so I mean, that
sometimes I have an urge,
and I'm, like, you know what?
I read the qualifications.
I'm like, I could
totally go for that.
But I see the level
of experience.
I'm like, obviously, being
out of college and things
like that, you don't have that.
But with technology nowadays,
those years of experience
aren't really relevant
to what's happening.
So I wanted to get your
opinion on those postings.
CHARLOTTE RELYEA: It's
a really good point.
And there's two
sides to that coin.
So one is the way in which the
job posting is being written.
And should you write it--
well, no, actually, let
me take a step back.
It is very much
proven over and over
that women tend to hold a
higher bar for themselves.
A man and a woman will go
into the exact same review.
And the woman will come
out and say, oh, my god,
I did, like, here are the
700 things I did terribly.
And the man will be,
like, I rocked it--
literally, the same language.
And similarly, exactly as you're
saying, men will be like, ah,
four years experience?
I was in college for four years.
You know, and a woman will
be, like, oh, no, I had four--
I have six years of experience.
But four of that, two of
them weren't exactly right,
and blah, blah, blah.
Like, it is just human
nature, and a lot of studies
have shown that.
So there's two things
to do about that.
One is to educate
women on self-advocacy,
and how do you start
to think about yourself
and actually reach higher,
reach harder, and be
OK with taking more risks
and things like that.
And I think that is actually
an important part of it.
And we, for example, at
McKinsey do a lot around that.
Which is how can
you raise your hand
and ask for more opportunities
and be more-- you know,
if your male counterpart
is going and asking
all these other
people for promotions,
you can do the same.
And then secondly,
I think there's also
the part about the writing
of the job posting.
So if we know that women
read it that way, maybe
trying to shift the language a
little bit so it doesn't say--
you know, it seems that the
four years of experience
is more of a nice to have or
you can write it in such a way
that you're not
playing to that bias.
I think that's a
really good point.
AUDIENCE: One more.
CHARLOTTE RELYEA: OK, one more.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You were talking a lot about--
thank you for being
here, firstly.
So this study is
super interesting.
You were talking a lot
about self advocacy.
But early in the study,
we heard about how
women who advocate
a lot for themselves
are perceived to be
aggressive or bossy.
How do you manage
those two perceptions?
CHARLOTTE RELYEA: So that's
a really good question.
I think that it's about
managing away the bossy issue.
I think the answer
is not to let women--
not to tell women,
OK, well, then just
operate within that bias.
It's that we have
to change the bias.
So you're right.
I mean, I think there's--
women get called-- it's a
double-edged sword, right?
I mean, it's sort of like
the damned if you do,
damned if you don't.
Where do we stand?
But I think you just--
I mean, self-advocacy--
I think that the bar,
the barrier between how
women self advocate, or the sort
of the gap between how women
self advocate versus
men is even bigger
than the gap between
how women are
perceived as bossy versus not.
So I would just sort of--
even though they are linked,
I would separate the two
and address them each
equally, because I think
they're both very important.
And it's better
to be called bossy
and still get the promotion--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARLOTTE RELYEA: --you know,
than to not get it at all.
- Thank you so much.
This was awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
- And thanks to all of you.
Because it was a
really great show.
And you gave some
fantastic advice.
The other thing that struck
me as I was listening
was just the awesome advice
that you gave each other.
And so I hope that each of you
takes away at least one nugget
from this conversation, whether
from Charlotte and McKinsey,
or from what some of
your colleagues shared.
And I passionately believe the
way we address this over time
is really the continuity
of the conversation.
So many of the things
that we talked about,
if we're able to sort of
quickly and easily bat
back and forth what
we heard, what we saw,
what the impact was, we will
consistently get better.
So please keep the conversation
going, both in these settings,
but also in the hallways.
And continue to look to
each other and to all of us
for tips to move this forward.
Thank you guys so much.
[APPLAUSE]